hallo leute ich jetzt eure mal waren
willkommen zu einem neuen look back und
heute habe ich dann gucken gemacht also
pancakes mit einer schönen er
platzierung und ich habe orangensaft
kaffee und milch und wasser ich konnte
mir nicht so ganz entscheidend was ich
dazu trinken möchte
und bevor jetzt wenn ich aufstehe habe
ich jetzt alles da also holt euch was
sie gerade frühstückt oder euer zimmer
aufräumt oder einfach nur im bett liegt
genießt es bevor ich aber startet welt
noch einmal werbung machen denn ich
möchte euch noch ob mein letztes koch
video hinweisen wo ich mit fabian
siegismund knäckebrot gemacht habe
falls sie es noch nicht gesehen habt
schaut unbedingt mal vorbei denn heute
kommt auch das neue geo wer aus also god
of war
wenn ihr euch das holen wollte holt euch
das dort gibt's am gewinnspiel also
falls ihr eine ps4 gewinnen wollt geht
macht das video klickt auf den link und
dann habt ihr vielleicht ein bisschen
glück und jetzt geht es weiter mit dem
video
ich hatte heute morgen lange überlegt
was hörte essen möchte und dann hatte
ich richtig lust auf pancakes ahornsirup
und seht euch das mal anders ist das in
finsternis
ich krieg das jetzt einfach mal drauf
ich verstehe nicht warum die amerikaner
das immer machen weil dann sind ja alle
deine pancakes voll mit soße
oh wie ist das schön mal haben wir das
auch erledigt das thema heute finde ich
besonders spannend weil ich wenig aus
meinem privatleben zähle und heute soll
es um geschwister gehen also wie fühlen
sich geschwister von youtube was haben
youtuber soviel geschwister wie ist es
so alles rund um diesen job
man hat ja auch noch das normale leben
in der familie und dann im privaten ist
man doch irgendwie schon so ja in einer
anderen welt sag ich jetzt mal gesucht
warum soll es heute gehen aber vorher
ein wissen das funktioniert gar nicht
wie im fernsehen
superlecker frau ich möchte dass da
drauf haben kennt ihr dieses
philadelphia milka das habe ich letztens
erst wieder gekauft weil ich das früher
hat es rauskam vor irgendeiner zeit voll
gerne gegessen habe und jetzt habe ich
das mal wieder gekauft und ich muss
sagen es schmeckt so ein bisschen
obwohl sie fast wie eiskonfekt
eiskonfekt sind ja diese kleinen
pralinen aus diesen spitz typen die man
kalt essen soll also diese schokolade
und so ein bisschen erinnert mich das
daran
ich kann ja nicht ganz sagen ob das
super lecker oder super eklig
habt ihr auch so lebensmittel besagt
dass hass oder liebe mit verbuchen
funktioniert es auf jeden fall sehr gut
weil ich meine den turm kleiner ich
mache zwei türme man erst das muss man
die zwei türme
ich habe letztens habe unter meinem
letzten mal habe ich gesehen dass ich
hier immer du überhaupt dass ich laut
esse ich es ein bisschen lauter aber
schau dir doch nicht morgen haben wir
nun nicht immerhin beim essen zu schauen
kannst oder nicht ist aufregt wenn leute
zu laut essen das ist halt so wenig
haking macht mir das manchmal hält
watching sachen gucken wir eigentlich
super schweiz findet einfach nur
irgendwie hast also ich glaube es gibt
viele youtuber die hält gerutscht werden
ich nenne es mal keine namen aber ich
bin selber oft auf kanälen wo ich sage
das interessiert mich eigentlich
überhaupt nicht aber ich muss mir
einfach ich muss es anschauen und mich
aufregen
es tut mir einfach gut natürlich darf
die sonne nicht mehr
sorry die kattas grad voll gewesen und
man musste ich sie wechseln wobei ich
genau das geht haltung geschwister und
da wäre meine erste frage an euch habt
ihr geschwister wenn ja wie viele
ich habe tatsächlich drei geschwister
also wir sind vier kinder und ich habe
früher oder eigentlich mein ganzes leben
immer gedacht ist dass vieles und es ist
auch viel oder
ich weiß noch nicht ob es wirklich sehr
viel isst oder wisst ihr was ich meine
also ist das schon dieses typische
großfamilie wie man sind werden nun
sieht die wollnys oder sind wir
eigentlich noch in ordnung ist in
ordnung wir hatten ein schönes leben
nun mein gott mein teller und sahne
ich sagte sammer baden 2018
es ist ja bald wieder soweit also ich
will das war mal auch wieder machen
es ist ja aber erst ab dem 21 juni
sommer jetzt meine frage an euch soll
ich schon vorher sommer noch machen
obwohl sonderlich offiziell sommer ist
aber es ist ja schon so warm dass man
sagen kann dass sommer ist also draußen
ist es die wii gerade gerade heute bis
24 grad so das ist ja also das schon
sehr mag oder nicht genau an der heutige
von euch wissen sagt ihr okay ich kam
ein bisschen erwarten macht bitte nur
dann oder york operiert
ich möchte auch mal nicht so lange
machen also bis zum ende des sommers
das war mal doch ist ja wirklich nur
vermag nur falls ihr das noch nicht
kennt ist ein format das war wirklich
diese lücke im sommer stopfen das loch
stopfen haha nein die soll das loch
stopfen
weil man ja eh nicht so viel auf youtube
abhängt also schon abends und so aber
weil es so warm ist in sommerferien so
man hat halt wenig zeit für internet und
in dem format man einfach ein paar
themen so ein bisschen news format in
dem moment ein bisschen was gefällt mir
also ich mag ganz viele youtube formate
während der zeit immer eine sendung und
da es geht um so den sommer
[Musik]
also geschwister ich habe drei
geschwister eine größere schwester und
zwei größere brüder
mein ältester bruder ist ja ich glaube
34 könnte sein
ja ich glaube es 34 mit dem können wir
jetzt nicht merken
eine größere schwester ist 30 und mein
größerer bruder ist 26
ja und ich bin jetzt 24 und werde bald
25 also ich war immer die kleinste was
hat auch wirklich sehr von vorteil ist
muss ich sagen weil wenn du zu viert
bist dass die kleinste zu sein heißt
eigentlich dass du nie schuld hast du
nie was machen muss und alle nur auf
dich aufpassen
man wird auch so kicken haft erzogen
immer also ich muss ehrlich sagen auch
noch heute ich bin ja jetzt eine
erwachsene frau aber für niemand in
meiner familie bin ich die große die
erwachsene
ich bin für immer alle zeit ich werde 90
sein klapprig alt mit einem gehstock mit
meiner eltern oder hätte mit mir leben
meine geschwister vielleicht auch nicht
mehr leben lang mit 70 und wird trotzdem
noch das küchenteam
ich bin eine erwachsene frau bittet
behandelt mich auch so oh mein gott die
erdbeeren
so mein großer bruder mein großer bruder
ist ja zehn jahre älter als ich das
heißt mit dem habe ich nicht also wir
hatten nie so einen tiefen kontakt die
geschwister sind aber wir waren nicht so
wirklich befreundet oder so meine
schwester ist sechs jahre älter als ich
und als mit kleiner waren bin ich immer
ziemlich auf den sack gegangen
also ganz ab wenn ich jetzt zurück
überlege was meine schwestern mir dafür
geschichten erzählt wie ich da den heim
tag an ihre doppel an ihrer tür geklopft
hat weil ich rein wollte sie mich nicht
rein gelassen hat und dann voll stress
mit meinem vater habe weil er darüber
ein gebäude das sie mich endet reihen
lassen soll
und sie war halt ein teenager und ich
war ein kleines kind so wenn ich ein
teenager bin dann will ich in ruhe
gelassen werden nicht von meiner
schwester die ganze genervt werden
und an dieser stelle entschuldigen
ich bin auch tatsächlich auf dieses
thema gekommen weil ich später in die
heimat fahren weil meine schlüsse
geburtstag hat und dann dachte ich dass
es mal ganz cooles irgendwie mal über
geschwister zu reden weil ich finde
geschwister außer dass man manche sieht
vor die kamera ziehen und hat dieses
thema lesen ich auch was davon ich lese
nie in der zeitung von geschwistern
was ist mit dieser art sind geschlossen
und mein größerer bruder ist 26 und der
war während meiner kindheit oder als wir
aufgewachsen sind waren wir schon so
beste kumpels also ich wollte auch als
kind immer die gleiche frisur wie er
haben und meine eltern oder meine
schwester sollen wenn wir eltern als
partner so schrecklich weil ich hatte
halt so schöne lange braune haare und
dann habe ich mal gesagt nein ich möchte
so kurz wie quito
das ist mein bruder und irgendwann nach
meiner kommunion genau die wollten noch
die haben mit mir den die gehabt
kommunion sollte ich noch die haare
behalten solange damit dass wenn ihr
mich was die kommunion ist wenn du
katholisch bist dann hast du eine
kommunion in der dritten klasse ungefähr
tricksen abartig weiß großes
glitzerkleid also du siehst wirklich aus
wie eine braut ich sah ausländer brauche
ich ja den schleier und meistens gleich
und dann wirst du quasi in die kirche
aufgenommen
also das ist wie eine konfirmation wird
sie das geld jetzt auch nicht kennt dann
müssen auch eine kirche aufgenommen und
ja dann hatte ich da diese kaum
und danach habe ich dann endlich mal die
kurzen haare bekommen und danach haben
uns die leute verwechselt also meinen
bruder und mich
wir sehen uns halt so ähnlich und mit
den haaren als in dem alter haben die
leute unter wechselt das war mein wille
ich fand ihn halt auch immer so cool bei
der wahl ihrer eltern
das heißt er durfte mal ein bisschen
mehr als ich ein bisschen weiter laufen
erfand den immer schon richtig cool
ja und das sind meine geschwister und
wir waren immer so zwei paare also meine
älteren beiden geschwistern mini und ich
und mein kleiner bruder älterer bruder
ihr wisst was ich machen will man so
aufgeteilt
ja und ich muss ehrlich sagen also ich
habe als kind doch schon öfter gedacht
so warum haben also warum sind wir so
viele so meine freunde kriegen das und
das weil sie halt einzelkinder sind oder
nur ein geschwisterpaar haben meine
eltern mussten halb vier kinder sorgen
ich an meiner stelle also wenn ich jetzt
logisch darüber nachdenke ich würde
niemals sagen
vier kinder würde ich gerne haben das
kann sich doch kein mensch leisten jetzt
mal ernsthaft ein kind kostet irgendwie
100000 euro im gesamten leben glaube ich
gehört zu haben kann aber mit stimmen
also ist viel geld und klar wenn du auf
einmal vierlinge hast oder ob es ein
unfall passiert dann das war irgendwann
beruflichen dann aber so geplant meine
mutter heute viele kinder krise und als
kind dachte ich immer so und wie heute
denke ich mir so etwas was es war ganz
klar wir waren viele kinder die großen
konnten auf die kleinen aufpassen die
kleinen mussten gar nichts machen
ich konnte den ganzen tag
liegen um eine grille eltern geschwister
kam zu mir und haben mir geholfen
ja nee also das war schon ganz gut
ja und ich jetzt sehe euch jetzt auch
eine story die habe ich euch noch nie
erzählt ich finde aber die gehört zu
meinem leben dazu
ich teile mein halbes leben im internet
also finde ich erzähle euch auch die
story als ich 13 14 war mein bruder 60
der achten klasse und mein bruder war in
der zehnten oder war ein erneuter stimmt
ich warne 8 und er war auch einmal
sitzengeblieben ist ja ich meine 8 und
ehrbaren erneuten und ja eines tages
rief die lehrerin von meiner mama und
meinem bruder und dann hat sie gesagt ja
der ihr sohn ist umgekippt
krankenwagen kommt schon vielleicht
kommen sie jetzt auch und dann sind wir
auf dem weg zur schule gewesen
ich habe irgendwie früher frei an dem
tag und dann ja hatte mein bruder
einfach einen herzstillstand also kein
herzinfarkt wurde es jetzt was andere
smartesten waren stillstandes ist jetzt
aber stehen geblieben und eine stunde
lang hat der schulsanitätsdienst der
schulsanitätsdienst ihn wiederbelebt sie
mussten die ganze zeit ihn wieder wieder
beleben weil er hat immer wieder weg war
ja und der krankenwagen kam halt
austausch mit 1 stunden lang hat der
schulsanitätsdienst nicht gemacht das
würde er geißelt eine heißt ja dass er
krank waren dann so spät gekommen werden
also auch hier fall haben sie aber ganz
lange und dann ich glaube mit 30 - 20
minuten oder so kam der krankenwagen und
die haben halt auch noch weiter
wiederbelebt weil die müssen den ganzen
stabil kriegen damit sie dann ins
krankenhaus kommen so ja da lag er und
konnte dann irgendwann ins krankenhaus
gebracht werden aber schon an dem abend
war es nicht gut also an dem abend ist
es schon dass es nicht also dass sie
keine hoffnung haben dann arzt geklappt
sag ich mal so er wurde verlegt und ein
anderes krankenhaus dann auf eine
intensivstation dann potenz koma
versetzt dann haben sie uns gesagt der
wird bald aufwachen dann
bringen sie mal schon mal sachen wobei
dann haben wir sagt vorbeigebracht dann
haben die aber an dem tag gesagt sie
können sich jetzt verabschieden
dann haben wir uns von guter
verabschiedet dann hat er die nacht doch
überlebt weil mein bruder einfach mit
fackeln kämpfer ist und ja für ging das
eine ganze zeit lang also er war auch
schon so drei monate im koma und die
ärzte haben ganze zeit versucht meine
eltern davon zu überzeugen die geräte
abzustellen weil die ganze gesagt haben
ja mit gemüse im kopf sein so und das
wird halt also so dass da ist halt nicht
viel mehr zu machen und ob bin ich auch
meine hände die organe spenden wollen
und mein vater war schon langsam so auf
diesem weg um vielleicht aber mit der
mutter der kannst du nicht mehr kannst
du nichts einreden hat wenn die glaubt
dass mein bruder so schafft dann ja und
tatsächlich ist mein bruder dann
irgendwann aufgewacht als er darin ein
anderes als eine reha versetzt wurde und
dann fing da halt alles von vorne an
er hat wieder sprechen gelernt wieder
essen trinken und heute ist es so das
ist jetzt schon fast zehn jahre her aber
das ist schon
doch hughes ist zehn jahre her oh mein
gott auf jeden fall sitzt heute im
rollstuhl und macht therapie ganz viel
er ist irgendwie blind irgendwie auch
nicht er sieht halt wirklich nicht
manchmal hat man aber das gefühl dass er
dann doch ausgesehen hat die bilder
werden aber falsch im gehirn verarbeitet
das heißt er kann es nicht so ganz sagen
wer kann nicht sagen oder auch eben
gerade etwas gesehen weil die bilder ist
es wie bei blinden die nie gesehen haben
da kannst du dir ja auch nicht erklären
wie es gerade ist das zu sehen so und
wenn die ideen sind nicht hast dann ist
es so und das ist so ein bisschen bei
ihnen wie mir klar als diaz zu sehen
dann weiß ja nicht genau was überhaupt
sehen ist es ist seine bilder im kopf
oder hat wünscht was also ist so ein
bisschen kicken
sein humor sein charakter ist komplett
da natürlich hat sich so ja wer
verhalten teenager das passierte sie
dass er schon 26 das sieht auch ein
bisschen anders aber
er zeigt komplett er
und wenn ich mir vorstelle ist die
damals echte geräte abgestellt hätten
so krass und gerade ist ja auch in genau
das wollte ich halt auch noch in dem
bezug sagen bei ich habe jetzt auch ein
paar mal die nachgekommen so vanessa du
machst ja gerade bewerben und so ja mein
bruder ist gerade in polen ein sonar
reha wo er ganz viel machen kann und die
krankenkasse wollte das diesmal nicht
bezahlen und dann haben wir halt
überlegt wie wir das geld dafür an
kriegen dann habe ich überlegt einen
spendenaufruf zu machen also euch um das
geld zu fragen vielleicht wird es auch
nochmal kommen wenn wieder irgendwas
anfällt aber ich war mir nicht so sicher
ob ich es in dem bezug euch erzählen
möchte also euch dann zu sagen hey mein
bruder sitzt im rollstuhl brauchen wir
hilfe an hier ist bitte das spendenkonto
sondern ich wollte euch das jetzt so
einfach von mir aus selbst erzählt und
ja und wir brauchten halt viel geld und
ich habe dann irgendwann gesagt dass ich
das übernehme für mich mit dem wissen
das ich jetzt halt ein paar also dass
ich ein bisschen mehr werbung machen für
eine 2 aber ich weiß halt warum
und ich weiß auch dass die leute die das
schreiben natürlich die werbung mache
und werbung wanne bin und so die maler
sind böse ich weiß es keiner
mich so wirklich persönlich angreifen
will
aber manchmal muss man auch verstehen
dass das leben nicht nur daraus besteht
geld verdienen und sich davon gut die
taschen zu kaufen sondern auch das geld
in andere sachen zu investieren und euch
nicht nach geld zu fragen sondern ist
auch mal einfach selber machen und dafür
hat eine werbung mehr mache ich finde es
absolut in ordnung mein gewissen ist
rein ich wollte nur erzählen und
besonderheit weil das thema geschwister
heute an liegt und ich einfach ich mich
nicht davon erzählen kann also das ist
so eine riesen teile mein leben mein
bruder ist mir so wichtig ich versuche
so viel wie möglich zeit mit ihm zu
verbringen
auf dem 187 konzert waren wir jetzt erst
letztens zusammen jetzt ist sehr
empfohlen
der hat halt nicht viel also der hat uns
freunde hatte noch aber es ist schon es
ist also das ist ein punkt wo sie sagen
das ist echt verdammt schwer dass ich
mein leben so leben wie ska tue ich habe
es mir selber aufgebaut
ich weiß es also ich weiß dass ich es
verdient habe ich weiß es ich es gemacht
habe
aber es ist noch mal was anderes wenn du
eigentlich täglich daran erinnert wirst
so nicht jeder hat so das glück nicht
jeder hat einfach dieses glück komplett
gesund fit zu sein möglichen die
möglichkeit zu haben
seine kreativität seine seinem hobby
nachzugehen
seiner passion und das ist schon es ist
schon glaube ich ein guter reminder
jeden tag dass ich weiß dass das was ich
habe und wie ich mein leben lebe und so
dass ich das schon glückspilz bin
besonders bei für meinen bruder jetzt
ein paar erinnerungen verloren oder
nicht erinnerung für den es halt so
berlin
wenn er weiß dass die hauptstadt ist es
berlin für ihn so hier also in seiner
vorstellung gegen abend feiern hatten
jeden tag auf der straße und alle leute
sehen musicals das ist berlin
das waren auf jeden fall so viele
pancakes aber die waren mega letter ohne
witz von wie schmeckt ich werde langsam
so gut im kochen erde niemals gedacht
dass ich so souverän in der küche stehen
kann wie es jetzt tue ich gucke vielen
sachen überhaupt gar nicht mehr auf
rezepte sondern mache einfach weil ich
weiß wie es geht so weil man halt viel
übung hatte ich habe mittlerweile auch
30 wie schmeckt's gedreht und ich hatte
gestern ein richtig gutes meeting mit
jemandem
der mit mir etwas machen ja mal gucken
dass wir auch schon ganz cool wenn das
klappen würde
ich bin jetzt ein richtiger youtuber
geworden der ich irgendwelche sachen
ankündigung ein wort zu sagen bitte
schön
ich war schon mal eure moneten memphis
geht das war hoffentlich geschwister so
oder so noch kurz mein bruder mein
großer bruder
der wohnt in polen hat dann schönes
leben aufgebaut hat da also erst
zurückgegangen weil meine eltern kommen
aus polen
und er ist in den ort zurückgezogen aus
denen meine eltern kommen weil da sind
halt viele verwandte viele freunde auch
von der familie und ja da hat er sein
geschäft aufgebaut meine schwester wohnt
noch in buxtehude also noch die von
altenburg wo sind meine buxtehude leute
ich wollte noch die und mit gott ich war
da noch die frage beantworten wie das er
ist für die als youtuber geschwisterkind
also mein bruder hat das alles so ein
bisschen belächelt mein großer bruder
er hat das immer belächelt bis ich dann
irgendwann damit im fernsehen war sogar
fantastisch und sodann hat er gedacht ok
klar weil er es geschafft meine
schwester die ja die hat genauso also
die die findet das immer so witzig wenn
ich von leuten erzähle die mit mir fotos
machen am boden oder oder sie wird halt
auch öfter mal angesprochen weil meine
nicht mit zum beispiel das auch erzählt
dass ich ihre tante bilden oder dann
wird sie halt angesprochen und dann sagt
sie so ja wie das ist nicht mal war das
ist meine schwester so weil es für sie
bin ich ja halt absolut die gleiche
personen wie mit 11 oder 12
und das ist glaube ich schon sehr
komisch es viele menschen halt nicht als
so ein superstar sehen wenn ich so was
da alles klingt übertrieben aber so als
merkte sie ist schon so superstar
das ist dann nur dann ziehen ist dabei
und mein bruder also quito der nacht
sich eigentlich immer mehr lustig
darüber wenn ich jetzt darüber nachdenke
der macht sich immer nur lustig und so
beim u bahn oder wenn wenn ich irgendwas
erzähle oder so weil er kann ja noch
super hören dann zieht er mich immer
noch mit auf das hat er schon immer
gemacht gut leute ich bin satt und ich
hoffe euch das video gefallen und wenn
ja dann gibt einen daumen nach oben und
ich freue mich aufs nächste mal